When it comes to balancing performance
versus visual fidelity, Unreal Engine gives you
several avenues of control.
For example, the quality of your volumetric fog
can be increased substantially through changing
various parameters and settings, as well as CVARs.
Note, in certain situations, for example,
such as ICV effects versus video games,
opting for higher quality visuals
over real-time performance may make sense.
You can always profile your scene's performance
by using stats, which are available from the viewport
dropdown, or using CVARs.
A pro tip for getting the maximum visual quality output
from your volumetric fog while still maintaining your editor
performance is to add CVARs to your movie render
cue output settings.
This will allow for the editor to use the cheaper, faster
volumetric fog settings while using
higher quality, slower performing settings when
exporting from movie render cue.
In the next video, we'll discuss using fog cards,
as well as localized fog volumes,
to create isolated areas of volumetrics.